[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in uh ernie johnson ernie do
you look at it that way when you're
nominated for a sports emmy if you don't
win did you lose
um
sure
i mean yeah no i always uh
you know what it's it's always a an
honor of course you were nominated
obviously
um
it did get a little old for years and
years to hear the name bob costas
announced every time you were there uh
at the end of a three-hour extravaganza
but it's like playing basketball in the
jordan era that's what i always likened
it to when you know you're broadcasting
in the bob costas era and oh yeah and
you're not going to win
especially in an olympic year it was
just like
does the company i mean you don't have
to fly me up there you know i can i can
take it from
hundreds of miles away
but i i became really good at applauding
and making it seem like i was really
happy for bob
costas yeah it got to the point when he
would go up and accept it was almost
like he was embarrassed to do it
he would tell an anecdote and just sit
down
you know when they start to announce the
candidates and bob starts walking to the
stage that's when i that's when i went
wait a minute here
wait a minute here
uh
let me give the uh the uh full intro
here ernie johnson tnt inside the nba
and uh multiple sports emmy award winner
for outstanding
sports personality studio host coverage
of the western conference finals
continues tomorrow what is the bit on
inside the nba
that almost went off the rails
last night or any night
well when charles came in on the horse
yeah i mean that was that's his second
time on horseback during a western
conference final he did it in oklahoma
city
and then did it last night and i think
it was almost uh flawless
aside from the dismount
which so there's a horse wandering
around dallas today with trucks
hamstrings still attached to it uh but i
think that um
i mean i i think there have been a few
things that have worked in a few things
some things are perfect you know some
some gags that we do i mean when when
when uh kenny tried to duplicate the
kobe bryant uh
uh
new shoe unveiling by jumping over an
aston martin and then we kind of
rigged it in the in the studio or
actually in the parking lot that we ran
over and that was perfect but then
there are others that
just don't fly i can't there were there
have been so many that hey let's take a
shot and then it turns out not to be
very funny or it just falls flat
so to isolate one of those it would be
very difficult then it's hard to land
the planes when you're a host and you
have personalities your job is just
landing planes and yeah then you have
the moment where it feels like
shaq and charles are getting personal
and and this happened the other night
where it felt like it was a little more
personal with each other
out in san francisco
what role do you play when you know that
this might not be what we
thought it was going to be
i mean
folks need to understand too
that these guys are so tight
their families their moms were extremely
tight when when chuck's mom was still
around and and we talked to miss lucille
from time to time so they actually are
good our great friends
guys love each other
sure it gets heated sometimes and guys
you know when you're trying to decide or
trying to defend your point
yeah it gets a little
heated but i've never thought oh this is
out of control but i think the best way
for me to do those always
okay
let's move on that's good you know so
kind of your your bogus anchor laugh you
know it's just
monica you know it's one of those you
know it's like so um so every now and
then you just kind of diffuse it that
way and then and you realize there was
really nothing to defuse it's just tv
but then
obviously social media after that is oh
they're very thrilled oh this is you
know this is fixing to get you know and
it's it really isn't
well that's i always like when shaq goes
that's why you never won a title chuck
yeah like look at these yeah
yeah i i know that's exactly it's always
the fallback i and i always know that
the the uh
any disagreement is about to end when
that's brought up i mean that's like
shaq's last line of defense he's he's
already talked about the fact that what
team needs to do this no they need to
defend it this way no they don't think
and there's
like shaq's just done hey i got four
dudes that's the
i was at the jimmy valvano golf
tournament many many years ago and i'm
at a table with digger phelps quinn
buckner
lou holtz barkley and michael jordan
and chuck is going back at michael a
little bit
and then all of a sudden the competitor
in jordan
kicked in
and then he started going for the knees
he was gonna he wanted to take out chuck
in front of us because chuck was getting
all these laughs
and then michael said
you never won a championship did you
and then all of a sudden it stopped
and then it wasn't fun it wasn't fun
anymore after that and you're like okay
you know that that that's
you can always win an argument it feels
that way when you go yeah you didn't win
a championship
well you know and to chuck's credit too
he's look he's lived with that forever
and it's brought up from time to time
and and so
you know he's
i don't know if he's okay with not
having one but he's okay with answering
that question
and and and so and i try not to go there
unless he's really made me mad
we're talking ernie johnson tnt inside
the nba i mentioned with luca he can get
40
but you're not going to win
championships when you have that
singular talent putting up these
incredible numbers and i always go back
to lebron with the cavs he wasn't going
to win a title
you know got to play for a title he
needed help michael jordan he was
averaging 36 a game
then he realized that he needed help
what would be the best running mate for
luca if you were going to handicap this
of what dallas's next move is to maybe
take them up to the next level because
the west is going to stay really really
really competitive for a while
yeah i mean it's uh and to your point i
mean last night
scores 40 but they're
oh and three when he scores for 40. and
so
uh
i don't i mean you've already got on
that team a bunch of shooters i mean
guys who can hit three pointers but
unless i mean maybe you need a
an absolute knock down no question about
it guy who's gonna
hit threes there i mean this is it's a
i'm the worst guy to try to say well you
need to pair this guy with him i just
think you know we've seen this dallas
team as it is
i mean
they beat the phoenix suns in seven
games playing the style that they play
that's five out you know and you come
down and space the floor and
uh sometimes i think i just think it's
more of a
make a more concerted effort to get
those other guys involved rather than
being just the guy who's got the ball in
his hands 99 of the time um
so that would be um i think just the
distribution is more of an issue than it
is personnel
what do you make of this this year's
version or this version of the warriors
uh to me is
look i've always liked watching them
play
i mean there are certain teams then
where
when i'm up late working on stuff at my
home office
you know and there's a game on
and for years it was like oh golden
state's plan to watch or back early on
it was like oh the suns are playing i
love watching steve nash and amari you
know i think those are entertaining
styles of basketball for me golden state
is is doing that again
i just love watching the ball movement i
love how crisp it is i love how this the
sixth sense that they all seem to have
of like the other night when steph kind
of got
wrapped up in a corner and just threw
the ball back over his shoulder and
draymond was there at the top of the key
and then fed it right back to when he
knocked down a three and it's like
you don't see that with everybody so i
um
and i think so i i think what i like
is the way steve kerr
has always described that team i like
the joy that they show when they're
playing who you know and i think that's
uh i think that's kind of been the
baseline common denominator of those
championship teams and this one there's
a joy when they play basketball
celtics in the heat um
i thought it would go seven but i didn't
expect
miami to win the this past game i
thought okay boston will get one in
miami i didn't know if miami could get
one in boston the health issue here i
mean try to handicap that series
i don't know where you start
no it's it's the same
i feel this is the same way you did um
but i also i knew going in look they
both they will both get up in you for 48
minutes okay so that's so they're both
good defensive teams the question was
okay pj tucker is he i think pj tucker
is so huge on the miami side that if he
ever that if he sits
that really hurts i mean it's it's kind
of a marcus smart kind of an edge that
he gives them
uh but i'm watching that game the other
night and i'm seeing that it's uh 46 to
20 as i'm watching it and i'm like well
this one's you know this game's over and
then i was convinced with two and a half
minutes left that the seltzers are gonna
win i said jeez it comes all the way
back now i know somebody's gonna do
something so it's been crazy it's like a
last man standing uh
series you know who's gonna get the next
injury i was looking for the wheelchair
to come out for marcus smart the paul
pierce chair and and it was like oh man
he because that was a bad role so
uh
let's see i have no idea i have no idea
all i know is jimmy butler is is really
good this time of year that
pj tucker is just like this all the time
and i love the edge he brings and and
there's no way jason tatum's going to
shoot again like that in game four so
um
if you're asking for a prediction i have
no idea but
that's the way this one's been
ernie's going to be hosting the match
the golf event that's june 1st you got
tom brady aaron rodgers patrick mahomes
and josh allen
yeah
what do you want to get out of these
guys
is it uh
some you know i just think
that's a good question and and it's
i did the first you know i did the first
match with tiger and phil
um
and
i just think you you have so many things
going on then you've got so many mics
being worn by so many guys and then
you've got me and chuck and whoever had
been trevor rimmelman and amanda
valeonis i mean you've got like
40 people with mics on
and now play golf and and you don't want
to step on
everything that you know if somebody's
talking you don't want to step on them
you just i think i'm just going to kind
of be there to make sure that chuck gets
some touches and that um
i think
um i i just kind of want the feel of hey
what if what are four athletes what do
four football players talk about when
they're out there you know and what kind
of you obviously you want the needle out
you want some trash talking a little bit
you hope you get some of that
um
so i don't know i mean
what do you want to get out of it when
you sit down to watch it what do you
what
because this is this will be good for me
i'll think about this the whole time so
what would dan be what is dan thinking
as he sits on the sofa would you get a
wristband you know like just put the
initials what would dan do i mean that
would be kind of nice
wwd yeah hold it up hold it up during
our our eye on camera welcome welcome
everybody um
no i
what i mean what do you want out of us
out of a situation like that what do you
want to hear you just want to hear guys
kind of trash talking well when when
brady had his pants ripped
and then he holds out from the fairway
and he's given charles grief like having
real moments
is you know i don't want to be a nice i
want them to be needling each other and
then
almost encouraging them to
this is your guy's tv event
how do you guys want to be portrayed
here because you can guide
but then i think it sounds like your guy
you don't want it you just want it to be
like where brady says something to
mahomes right away or aaron rodgers says
something to josh allen and then you go
okay this is on and and you have sort of
that feeling where they give you nuggets
along the way i mean i'd love to know is
brady ever played golf with bill
belichick
right i mean i mean those those are the
kind of things i think as they're as
they're
in their carts going to the next shot
that's what you and i think we've seen
that in the past too it's like
uh hey you've been working on how many
how many hours do you spend on the range
right do you practice let me get aaron
rodgers told us last night no i don't
practice man i just play you know and so
yeah let's hear i i do want to hear some
of that and i think in the course of 12
holes i believe is the
length of the event that we will
that we will uh
get some of that but i'm with you you
don't want to sound like you're forcing
somebody to say something they don't
want to say i think i think we're kind
of in this privileged position where
where
look we got mics on this bunch it's like
if you were at the golf course and you
said
look at that foursome over there playing
on number seven that looks like tom
brady and
and aaron rodgers i'd love to know what
they're saying and that's kind of why
we're there and and and i think
it's up to us to listen to it and then
pick up on something and say hey that
was interesting what he said go into
that a little further explain that and
then at the same time having fun and
and uh
so that's it but again
and you know what this is like
you've got
a million different voices and you just
don't want anybody to
feel left out or feel like okay you've
got to talk now because you haven't said
anything i i think you'll be hearing me
a lot of times just saying
you're watching the match and we'll be
back with more from las vegas
how come only 12 holes
i think that's just the format they're
doing that's one they did last time too
um and it's going to be a what do you
call it a shamble
where you
uh
everybody tees off
you know my team we pick which tee shot
we're going to hit and then everybody
plays the ball coming in from there so
um
it's kind of like like we played a
scramble at the black masters the other
day me and
uh sam mitchell taking on charles and my
son eric as charles did win the black
the coveted black jacket
really first time yeah
chuck's playing man
swinging the golf club
ernie i played with charles years ago
has to be years ago um and he shot a 79.
sure and
and then all of a sudden he was trying
to get better he changed his somebody
said pause at the top of your backswing
pause for a second
and and that's what that's where it all
went downhill but i remember playing in
an event a sanctioned event those
celebrity golf tour events he shot a 79.
sure i mean i heard those same kind of
stories and then uh
in the time that i've known him in the
last you know or worked with them the
last 20 you know 21 years or something
i i do agree with you that i think he
looked at one of these tapes that that
breaks down the swing from here here
here and and paused you know it did and
he took that literally
it's going to be really hard to
complete my swing if i keep stopping
like this but
he's got uh stan utley is his is his
guru now
and he has fixed the chuckster dan i'm
telling you
you know 300 plus drives right down the
middle really are all without question
without question he is killing the ball
and
eddie's got some touch and so
um
[Music]
look he's he has come back and and then
sam and i uh
lost to him on the 18th the other day in
fact he
chuckster
chuckster needed to get up and down from
a green style bunker at the lovely
legends course at chateau long
and uh
and
he's stuck at about
18 inches
it's unbelievable i'd love to see shaq
out there
wearing wearing a golf outfit where he'd
have the you know the the like payne
stewart hat
any dad
plus plush
color coordinated and and just finding
clubs that shaq could play
well no i think even the key to that
would be no you can't play uh
clubs that you can play here's a junior
set
i think that would i think that would be
even better
and you know what he would do it because
he's the world's largest kid and if he
thinks
because you know because you know what
it would happen he'd say if i knew that
it's going to get like 4 million
youtubers of course
that's exactly what it's all about
content king
uh good luck with the sports emmys
tomorrow night and uh i will i will not
be there i will be here in dallas
i would accept on your behalf
if you needed me too
uh you know our good our longtime good
buddy who who do you think
if you and i both know him who do you
think
would be if if in just in case i am
fortunate enough to win tomorrow night
yeah you and i both know him you've
worked with them before this would be
the guy who would yes tim kiley
tk yeah
the longtime legendary producer of
inside the nba i can get up there
quicker than he can my seats will be
better ernie
i'm just saying
because you guys whoever gets there
first okay because i would i would say
um oh ernie gave me a speech
first of all
um
suck it bob costas overrated
i don't need shaq i don't need charles
uh
you know then
that's exactly why tk is coming instead
of me
but you know what but he but i have uh
every reason to believe he'll he will
remain seated during my category yeah
uh tell the boys i said hello and uh
thanks for joining us as always
hey it's always great talking to you dan
thank you so much for having me on see
you guys ernie johnson ernesto is uh
nominated for sports emmy and uh he'll
be hosting the match that'll be june 1st
with brady and rogers mahomes and josh
allen and of course the western
conference finals continues tomorrow
night on tnt game four